tilag a ez egy nagyon fontos kérdés hogy
a kereszténység az egy változata a többi
vezetés elméletnek vagy a vezetés
elmélet amivel érdemes foglalkozni és
egyetértek ezzel eddig
hogy hogy nincs ideológiaamentes vezet
tehát valami mozgatja valamilyen szándék
valamilyen vezérel valamilyen mintázat
minden egyes szervezet működését és
kérdés az hogy h mi az ami mozgatja mert
hogyha nem beszélünk róla attól még
mindig mozgatja tehát a háttérben van
valami ami irányítja a figyelmet az
erőforrásokat és a döntéseket ha egy
kapitalista mondhatná valaki azt hogy
engem most nem érdekel ez a sok minden
én akarom intézni a dolgaimat azért hogy
hogy pénzt keressek de hogyha elkezdjük
kérdezni miért akarsz pénzt keresni meg
hogyan akarod az embereket motiválni meg
hogyan akarjuk a hogyan akarjuk a hogyan
készülünk fel a jövőre egyáltalán mit
gondolunk a jövőről mit gondolunk az
ember szerepéről tehát amikor elkezdünk
ilyen kérdéseket feltenni akkor vagy az
van hogy nem válaszolunk rá és úgy
próbálunk
ideológiaamentesek lenni hogy nincsenek
válaszaink vagy pedig elkezdünk
gondolkozni rajta é akkor már ezek már
filozófiai kérdésekké válnak mi az ember
szerepe a világban és mi is az ember
szerepe a világban ez egy nagyon fontos
kérdés és azt látom főleg
informatikusként hogy ez engem hamarabb
ért ez a kérdés talán mint a többi
szakmabeli ö többi embert aki elkezdett
dolgozni ezelőtt hát most már ti éve
mindjárt 20
éve mert az informatikusok sokat
keresnek és azáltal hogy hogy nagy a
fizetésük azáltal hamarabb jutnak el
ahhoz a kérdéshez hogy oké akkor miért
dolgozom mert az aki napi az aki
kevesebbet keres és az a célja hogy
többet keressen addig gyakorlatilag
elfedődik ez a kérdés gyakorlatilag
maximalizálni akarja a fizetését
szüksége azért akar több öbet dolgozni
és nagyobb fizetést szerezni hogy és
akkor kiegészíti a saját életcéljaival
de amikor már ez megtörténik egy
informatikus esetében akkor már sokkal
hamarabb elkerül ahhoz a kérdéshez hogy
miért miért dolgozok mi minek van
értelme és akkor ha ezt a miértet
felteszi
valaki körülbelül a 30-as éveire
közepére az emberek eljutnak ehhez a
kérdéshez így vagy úgy mert mert
történik egy váltás tehát ez a a
felnőtté válásnak a a a része amikor már
az a kezdeti eufória eltűnik hogy hogy
már dolgozok és van fizetésem és
utazhatok és ezt megtehetem és azt
megtehetem és akkor feltevődik a kérdés
rendben e e az egész miért van és akkor
ez ez ez egy nagyon
nehéz nagyon nehéz helyzet ez egy krízis
helyzet az ember életében és azt hiszem
hogy hogy részben ezért is van hogy a
szientológia ennyire terjedhet a
környezetünkben mert erre egy
alternatíva a miértre egy alternatíva de
ugyanúgy y válasz erre a miértre a
keresztény vezetés elmélet és akkor
visszatérünk az eredeti kérdéshez hogy
hogy a a a a a keresztény válasz az
mennyivel hatékonyabb válasz a miértre
mint bármilyen más válasz és ez itt
valójában akkor dől el amikor az ember
elkezdi praktikusan ezt élni tehát a a a
kereszténység számomra egy nagyon
praktikus vallás nem lehet elméletben
tehát elméletben sok mindent lehet
beszélni de amikor konkrétan elkezdünk
cselekedni és megnézni a
cselekedeteinknek a gyümölcsét abban a
pillanatban kiderül hogy milyen elvek
azok amik mozgatják a világot és én
ilyen elveket nagyon sokat kaptam
amielyekre rájöttem hogy legmélyebben
keresztény elvek most csak egyet mondok
a hallgatóknak de szerintem a következő
másfél óra ezzel fog telni hogy
folyamatosan beszélgettünk mindenféle
elvekről de számomra egy nagyon
megdöbbentő felismerés volt az hogy a
pszichológiának minden egyes iskolája
függetlenül a ól hogy hogy most rogery
vagy jungi vagy vagy freudy minden egyes
iskolája rájött egy alapelvre mégpedig
az hogy ha valaki
önként szembeszáll a félelmével annak
gyógyító hatása van tegyük fel félünk a
magasságoktól az egyik módszer arra hogy
hogy ezt le tudjuk küzdeni az az hogy a
problémát megfogjuk és lekicsinyítjuk
annyira kicsivé
hogy hogy hogy meg lehessen ezt ugrani
ezt a lépést tegyük fel valaki fél a
lifttől a bezártságtól hogy bentmarad a
liftbe akkor az első lépés az hogy
egyáltalán be oda tudsz-e menni egy
lifthez azt mondja a másik nem jó akkor
akkor itt van egy kép egy liftről rá
tudnál-e nézni a liftajtóra azt mondja
hogy nem akkor lépjünk még egy lépést
vissza
akkor próbáld meg a fejedben felidézni
azt a képet amelyik a liftajtóról szó
fel tudnád-e idézni és akkor azt mondja
tegyük fel hogy ezt most még meg tudnám
csinálni jó akkor idézzük fel rendben
akkor felidéztük a következő alkalommal
akkor meg tudnánk-e nézni ezt a képet
hát már már meg tudjuk nézni a következő
alkalommal akkor oda tudnánk-e menni egy
liftajtóhoz hát az még nem akkor a
kintről az ajtó tehát hogy a a a
távolról nézni a liftajtót megtudni azt
megtudjuk és akkor így fokozatosan
közelebb megyünk a lifthez utána meg
mernénk-e nyomni egy gombot igen akkor
utána be mernék-e úgy menni hogy utána
egyből ki is szállok a liftből és akkor
utána bemegyek és akkor ott maradok egy
pár másodpercet és és akkor megm úgy
nyomni azt a gombot hogy egy emelettel
megyek fennebb és lassan lassan az
emberek így képesek szembeszállni ezzel
az absztrakt sárkánnyal a fejükbe azért
mer azért absztrakt mert bár konkrétnak
tűnik de abban a pillanatban mihelyt a
liftel elkezdenek tudni élni és
használni mint eszköz abban a
pillanatban egy absztrakt feladatot egy
absztrakt félelmet győztek le a fejükbe
és az életük több területén megjelenik
egy pozitív változás tehát ez ez ebben
egyetért minden pszichológiai iskola és
valójában az elv mögötte az hogy ha
önként felvállaljuk a szenvedésünket ha
önként vállaljuk azt a fájdalmat ami
amin keresztül kell menjünk nem pedig az
áldozataivá válunk abban a pillanatban
ennek megváltóereje van ez a legmélyebb
gondolat a legmélyebb keresztény
gondolat ez egy ez egy hihetetlen
gondolat mert mert valójában ez a kérdés
hogy most egy szervezet melyik szervezet
működik jobban az amelyik képes arra
hogy önként szembeszálljon a félelmeivel
a változékony piaci realitásokkal a a a
belső konfliktusokkal vagy az amelyik
megpróbálja ezeket elpalástolni és
egyértelmű hogy az amelyik önként teszi
az sokkal de sokkal hatékonyabb mint az
amelyik amelyik nem önkénteszi úgyhogy
ez a mondjam úgyha a rövid válaszom arra
hogy miért tehát e ez ez például egy
mély keresztény elv a legmélyebb
keresztény nnyelv az önként vállalt
szenvedésnek a megváltóhása ez a
krisztusi kép amelyik a kereszten önként
vállalta a a a halált úgyhogy úgyhogy
úgyhogy igen számomra a keresztény
vezetés elmélet az egy ez az egy valami
olyan ami ami kimagasló a többi vezetés
elmélettel szemben ugyanis emberekkel
dolgozunk és ugyanúgy érvényes ez az
önként vállalt szenvedés minden egyes
emberre nem csak ránk hanem az egész
szervezeten végigvanul így
fraktálszerűen megismétlődik
mintaszerűen és és és áthatja az egész
kultúránkat és és az embernek szüksége
van arra hogy ne csak dolgozzon és éljen
napról napra hanem valami értelmes
legyen az amit csinál valami nagyobb
nakak legyen a része az a amit csinál és
kérdés az hogy mi minek a része ezek már
olyan kérdések amik már a miért elkötődn
miért élünk a földön mi mi értelme van
enni mi értelme van dolgozni egyáltalán
van-e értelme például gyermeket szülni
erre a világra ez ez is egy fontos
kérdés és van erre egy keresztény válasz
és van erre egy nem keresztény válasz is
én azt látom a keresztény válasz az
amivel ha valaki kapitalista módon önző
módon azt szeretné h a cége jobban
működjön akkor is érdemes a keresztény
gondolatokhoz hozzá
nyúlni de én mondjuk nem ezen a szinten
szeretem élni a keresztényvezetés
elméletet ahol ahol önző kapitalista
módon használjuk mint egy automata
ezeket az elveket hanem hanem az ahol
egy élő kapcsolatunk van istennel is
imádkozunk folyamatosan úgyhogy ez a
rövid válaszom a a a ezzel kapcsolatban
nem tudom te is hozzáfűzhetsz neked mi a
véleményed valami még megpengetődötte-e
benned ezáltal így
ami hát igazából azt azt látom és két
két itt itt érdemes egyből
különbséget tenni a a keresztény
vállalkozás vagy a keresztény vezetés és
a és a vallásos
ság között
és ez egy ez egy újabb dimenzió
keresztény vezetőnek lenni
a akár a kutatásaimból ugye ti 11 néhány
vállalkozóval készítettem é intervjút a
mesteri disszertációmhoz és és azt az az
egyik megállapítás hogy a a a keresztény
vállalkozó a kereszténységét a
vezetésben nem a nem
a keresztény menedzsment eszközökkel ha
létezik ilyen hogy megkeresztelt
menedzsment eszközökkel érje el
hanem hanem ezek a vállalkozók nem
tartják magukat a legfelsőbb szintű
vezetőnek mindannyian úgy gondolják hogy
hogy őket vezeti valaki és
szerintem a a többi ideológiái
ideológiai vezetés és a keresztény
vezetés között ez az egyik legnagyobb
különbség hogy maga a szolgálat és az
hogy vezetve vagyok itt jelenik meg
egyedül és itt jelenik meg a
legerőteljesebben hogy a keresztény
vezető az elsősorban attól keresztény
mint minden más keresztény ember hogy
élő kapcsolata van az istennel és és ez
az élő kapcsolat ez oda-avissza működik
és és van egy vezetettség benne és van
egy gy alázat hogy nem én vagyok a főnök
hanem hanem én a végrehajtó vagyok én
vagyok a földi végrehajtója annak a
vezetőnek aki aki ezt az egészet
eltervezte és vezeti és és azt látom
hogy beszéltem olyan vállalkozókkal akik
úgy fogalmaztak hogy ők már vállalkozók
voltak és vezetők több több 10 vagy akár
100 tagú vál vázást tehát
munkással létező vállalkozást vezettek a
megtérésükkor és azt mondták hogy
hogy nem 180 fokot
de ki se tudják fejezni hogy a megtérés
előtt és a megtérés után mekkorát
változott a akár a vezetéssel
kapcsolatos szemléletük a
vállalkozásukban
és és azt gondolom hogy ez a ez a
különbség hogy az ideológiá nagy része
az mondjuk úgy hogy ilyen ember által
barkácsolt és az ember van a csúcsán
a kereszténységnek a
csúcsán a golgotáján ott van az a az a
krisztusi megváltó mű amiről az előbb
beszéltél az önként vállalt szenvedés de
ott van a szolgálat és en a ezt az
alapelvet emelném ki igazából a a
vezetőnek a szolgálata
hogy aki ő akar lenni közületek az
legyen az utolsó és aki aki a
a a főhelyekre akar ülni az üljön üljön
hátrébb és vegyen vissza az arcából én
ezt így fordítanám le
[Zene]
magamnak és az hogy hogy krisztus
megmossa a lábait a
tanítványainak amikor ezt a szintű
alázatot és ezt a szintű szolgálatot
látod egy
vállalkozásba ennek megrendítő ereje van